con seis votos en contra y tres a favor
la corte suprema de justicia de estados
unidos bloqueó temporalmente la orden
ejecutiva del presidente joe biden que
exigía a las empresas de más de 100
empleados vacunar a todo su personal
obligarlos a hacerse las pruebas
semanales y portar máscaras la decisión
de la corte de mayoría conservadora sí
permitirá que se exija como el obligado
inicialmente el mandato presidencial a
que los trabajadores de la salud tengan
que vacunarse para trabajar en los
centros de cuidado médico financiados
por el gobierno 84 millones de
estadounidenses se iban a ver afectados
por la medida esto es casi dos tercios
de la fuerza laboral en el país pero
ahora serán 17 millones de trabajadores
médicos que tendrán que vacunarse o
portar máscaras y hacerse las pruebas
cada semana la decisión de la corte
suprema viene en medio del pico de
contagio de coronavirus en eeuu donde se
reportan más de 780 mil casos diarios de
contagio por vikram